what's up guys Ryan right over here and
ready fries over here we're gonna check
out the video from Screen Rant
ten huge mistakes you missed in
superhero movies let's do this
as more and more comic books burst to
life on the big screen the action
storylines and castes are only getting
bigger and bigger as a result some of
the simple mistakes and errors that
would normally be caught in editing are
slipping through more than ever and as
audiences grow more and more excited to
see their favorite heroes on screen some
massive mistakes have gone completely
unnoticed here are screen rants 10 huge
mistakes in superhero movies the general
Zod's Baldy Claude
although Man of Steel star Clark Kent
spent his entire life keeping his alien
heritage a secret General Zod spills a
secret to the entire world when the
Kryptonian first arrives on earth you
broadcast a message in multiple
languages around the globe telling
people in America and Asia that they are
not alone seeing people hug around their
campfires or TVs and learning that an
alien lives among them is a powerful
image but think about it all the scenes
are set at night no matter which side of
the planet there are yeah doesn't quite
add up
since the message of the scene is to
unite all of Earth in fear fans will
likely be willing to overlook it he
turned around tumbling Christopher Nolan
isn't afraid of leaving a few errors in
his films yeah the thrills are twists
they bring with them are usually worth
it in the end in the case of his
reimagined Batman the director bet that
audiences would be too thrilled to see
the new Dark Knight in action with a
signature set of wheels to notice a few
major mistakes during Bruce's first test
drive of the camo pattern tumbler he
brings the vehicle to a dramatic stalk
with a sudden slide but a closer look
reveals that Bruce turns the wheel hard
left a stop while the car ends aha
either that's an editing mistake or this
vehicle is really difficult to pilot
crowded chase oh no we're not done with
Nolan's Batman with you when the Dark
Knight finally takes his new tumbler
into the field Gotham City police
pursuit hasn't cornered atop a large
parking structure with cops swarming
Nolan clearly hopes audiences would be
too excited or caught up to notice the
massive group of crew members and
cameramen on set completely exposed by a
police choppers searchlight and he was
probably right oh my gosh Scotty Scott
when Wolverine and rogue pay a visit to
Bobby
aka ice man's family and x2 x-men United
the mutants brother calls the police who
ambushed the entire group on the house's
front porch a jumpy police officer drops
Wolverine with a bullet to the head
taking the situation from
add to worse fans knew that Wolverines
healing factor would bring him back to
the fight in no time but the actual shot
doesn't make much sense considering the
nearly invincible heroes usual fighting
skills the first question is how the
bullet managed to lodge itself in his
head in the first place a skull made of
indestructible adamantium means the
bullet should have glanced off
harmlessly instead of embedding itself
in his forehead why he was knocked
unconscious doesn't make sense either
despite making his claws and bones and
breakable is the same metal useless at
protecting his brain of course there's
always the chance the cop was firing
adamantium bullets but that seems like a
long shot long shot
shield logic one Steve Rogers finally
starts to prepare for field work gen
Captain America the First Avenger he
stumbles upon a prototype of this famous
vibranium shield described as completely
vibration resistant it succeeds in not
deflecting bullets but stopping them
dead in their tracks
it isn't just bullets either in the
Avengers its invulnerability is tested
stopping even for his hammer directing
his godlike attack into a massive
shockwave unfortunately in the effort to
make the Winter Soldier sequel and more
grounded and realistic adventure the
strengths of caps shield flew completely
out the window not only was Steve able
to use this shield to deflect bullets at
his enemies but kicks and punches were
able to knock him around and a single
RPG sent of tumbling through the air a
shifting Pentagon considering just how
much x-men Days of Future Passed deals
with time travel into rewriting history
plenty of inaccuracies can be explained
away is slightly different in the
alternate time although we're fairly
certain that in all realities the
Pentagon is technically located in
Arlington Virginia
not Washington DC a rogue key most fans
know that the original cut of Days of
Future past had the team of future x-men
seeking help from rogue after an
unconscious Wolverine mortally wounded
Kitty Pryde with Kitty's health failing
robe was brought in to absorb her power
and take over in the end Kitty was
simply shown to tough it out in the
finished version but the filmmakers
didn't remove the previous storyline
completely when a wounded Magneto slides
to the grounds of the final battle
reaches its conclusion Kitty is supposed
to be maintaining the link to the past
however she can just be spotted slumped
on the floor next to it her unique
costume design is pretty hard to miss
extremists measures not every Marvel fan
was happy to see Tony Stark separated
from his signature armor and Iron Man 3
but his gift for invention and careful
planning showed he was a threat with or
without his
even so the filmmakers may have turned a
blind eye to a few mistaken details the
brilliant dr. Maya Hansen threatens to
inject a syringe carrying 1200 CCS 1200
CCS it does half of this size Undead
an amount equal to 1.2 liters it's an
odd mistake for a character to make but
it wasn't the movies only inaccuracy
Tennessee Express Ironman threes
questionable madam continues when toni
realizes his suit in Tennessee's
finally been powered on-line stark asked
the henchmen on hand exactly what
distance the armor pieces need to travel
to reach it what's mileage count between
Tennessee and Miami 832 miles the
superstein just minutes later a major
problem when spans start doing the math
the payoff is worth it but the idea that
the pieces could travel around 7,000
miles per hour proves that comedy beat
out actual physics in this case identity
crisis for all its action the first Thor
movie served to prove one point that
godly power was a gift not a privilege
it turned out the Asgardian hero needed
to learn some humility he learned the
lesson in the end saving his father and
kingdom from his brothers betrayal
once Loki was beaten the would-be King
chose to fall into a wormhole in space
eventually making his way to the villain
Thanos and back to earth to fight the
Avengers years later but his family
mourns him all the same Thor even takes
a private moment to tell owning that he
could never be as good a king as he was
his father they'll never be a wiser King
with you the sentiment is returned at
the end of Thor the dark world when Odin
asks Thor if he still believes that the
father should rule and not the son you
once said that would never be a wiser
King than me it's a subtle call back to
the die-hard fans but there's one
problem the film ends by revealing that
it isn't Odin or Oni but Loki in the sky
upon the writers part is probably to
blame since there's no rope you should
know about the Paris conversation yeah
as he was off drifting through space
some might argue he was eavesdropping
from across the universe but we like to
think Loki has better ways to spend his
time so what do you think of our list
did we miss any of your favorite
mistakes your plot holes in superhero
movies let us know in our comment
section and don't forget to subscribe to
our channel for more videos like this
one
I kinda wish they went more into x-men
because x-men franchise they're known to
have the most inconsistencies when it
comes to like wait a minute this doesn't
make sense how this character was here
at this time and then blah blah like it
a lot of things just don't connect
properly but they kind of identified it
a little bit by saying that there's a
lot of time travel and the abilities of
the mutants yeah so one can argue that
but it's not made clear in the midnight
no it's not it feels like legit mistakes
of the movie made and they explain it
away by saying that yeah exactly exactly
dis dirty bastards I thought these were
gonna be more like specific like major
fuck-ups so these are just like editing
mistakes of things yeah mostly
you know like with General Zod and all
the countries around the world it's all
nighttime which doesn't make sense but I
never noticed that I didn't know no I
didn't even put it together I mean once
you point it out of course then it
really yeah cuz these mistakes are not
something that will pull me out of the
movie anything you know these are not
things wrong like oh that's that just
doesn't make sense like we also know
know they also probably thought that
would pull people out of the movie if
they weren't all in the same time zone
yeah I get what you're saying like if
it's in the day sometimes like it's only
the people that are diehard and it's
better dramatic effect when it's
nighttime Jimmy yeah yeah there's more
like darkness literately
Adams he literally and figuratively Oh
Zack Snyder we're defending you the one
thing that I did catch was the shield
Winter Soldier mmm-hmm and when I sold I
was like booop oh okay I'll take it and
then I just accepted it as it was yeah
yeah yeah because they do show in
Avengers that he can handle Thor's
hammer but when a [ __ ] RPG get shot
at and be searched flying and stuff so
that doesn't make much sense that's
that's what I mean like I wanted to see
more inconsistencies like that like how
they would know the x-men universe and
now with Winter Soldier because that
doesn't make sense but at the same time
these movies you're so pulled into them
you're so engrossed
them that sometimes you don't notice
things like that you're saying you
noticed it
yeah I actually that's the one that I
noticed all of the other ones I didn't
even notice but the cool one oh that was
Batman's car too when he was turning
turning the other way
yeah even realized it hiren even thought
oh I made a mistake in one of my short
films where um I have a soccer on my
dick and then I hit Alyssa with it and I
and I swing to the left but she falls to
the right oh so I know what it's like to
make those kind of mistakes people I
know what it's like editing stuff mm-hmm
blocking stuff yeah true the whole
Wolverine getting shot okay see that's
I'm talking about he gets shot in the
head and they're bringing up good points
of he hit you just pretty much deflect
off his head but in x-men origins
Wolverine he gets shot in the head and
loses all his memory yeah what happens
right so that's I mean with he's in
consider in one movie it's just like
then in another it causes him to lose
this whole memory I remember why I want
to saw that it didn't really bother me
yeah I didn't bother me either I was
like listen it's not a big deal but it
kind of makes will ring a little too
immortal for my opinion that's kind of
one of the things I don't really like
about it is Wolverine seems like very
much like unbreakable in that sense that
you just can't kill the guy and even
kill him um III don't know you read the
Bible then catches on fire
so Satanist that's overrated the one
with Loki was a great detail yeah I
guess yeah that's right Loki's falling
through the wormhole and all that [ __ ]
so there's no way he would have heard
that Loki is you know he's a smart guy
though Loki knows things
he's intuitive he's intuitive maybe he's
even telepathic meat yeah and you know
what he'd be good on dates Loki would be
great on dates I'm sure you get all the
ladies oh yeah man I mean I imagine Loki
participated in many an orgy probably
yeah I did that
proper he's able to create multiples of
himself - yeah
so he's [ __ ] every [ __ ] at once or
himself or himself that's the ultimate
method I'm a masturbation me I've cloned
yourself in your so so yeah identity
crisis indeed anyway guys thanks for
tuning in to the channel if you're new
to it you could subscribe to the real
rejects you check out brandy prices
channel it's a fun channel there check
it out now get out you could follow us
on Facebook Instagram Twitter I have a
vine and periscope I don't think she
does let's do a shout out
Devon Hanh [ __ ] her right in the [ __ ]
in all seriousness keep up the good work
Devon maybe he got it right wrong like
[ __ ] her right in the [ __ ] yeah it's
just leave yeah maybe he's his best I
[ __ ] her right in the [ __ ] or right and
I don't know and what was he talking
about
I don't know you know probably nothing
do that to her oh I don't like girls
with shorter hair shoulder line I like
it to be longer or girls that were pink
yeah I'm not a big fan of girls or pink
or disco pants galaxy pants galaxy I'm a
girls regality
Neil deGrasse Tyson you're really pinked
out today hey you're like really pinked
out yeah pink out this think out I don't
know guess that's why he's talking about
cuz the sending the fact he should have
sent pink [ __ ] her right in the [ __ ]
yeah then it would have apply more to
this video probably shoutout